có việc hôm nay là năm 2019, ngày mắt của chủ thịt của Chí Minh, theo âm lịch,
tại đến thời bác hồ trên định mối vua, vận cuối ra bà vị,
được sự phân công của các đồng trí lãnh gạo của lãnh đạo đàn,
nhà đứa, có thủ thưởng của đức phức,
và đoàn công tác đã kính cần giấm vương,
thường giữa chủ thịt của Chí Minh vi đại.
Mày tòa là ông biết ơn vô hạn và kính trong sâu sắc,
đối với chủ thịt của Chí Minh, lãnh tù vi đại của đàn của dân tộc,
và như dân tà, anh không dài phóng dân tộc,
người sáng lập và giải luyện đàn cộng sang Việt Nam,
người đã công hiện khi sinh chọn lời cho sự nghiệp dài phóng dân tộc,
nấu tranh cho hoa mình và hạnh phúc của dân tộc Việt Nam và Ninh dân thế giới.